I know guys getting into consulting can
be very tough as a former ex McKinsey
strategy consultant today I'm going to
share my best tips and strategies what
you can do to get into consulting hi
guys how is it going welcome to another
coffee break with firm learning my name
is high-enriched and welcome to my
channel today I have something special
for you because yesterday I did a
webinar for the Munich student society
talking about how to break into
consulting I have the whole recording
here for you in a truss it has been an
excellent session with lots of value in
an extensive Q&A at the end
below in the video description I'm
leaving timestamps for you to see all
the individual questions and sections so
there are only specific elements that
interest you feel free to check the
video description to directly jump to
the parts that interests you most
unfortunately the start of the session
introduction got missing but basically
the only thing that you need to know is
that in the beginning I introduced
myself I talked about my educational
background studying in Munich London and
the later the MBA and France and
Singapore in the north of my
professional background working as a
consultant later as a project leader at
McKinsey for total of about six years in
our recently transitioning into a CTO
role at a German fashion retailer
I then talked about how from my
perspective there are three main
elements when you think about how you
break into consulting first what's the
right experiences that you need to get
in second how you should set up your
written application materials and third
the interview how you get the interview
right so the webinar is set up in a way
that are first given an impulse on these
three topics and then I open it up for
Q&A with lots of student ask me
questions as always if you took any
value out of the video door please hit
the like button for the YouTube
algorithm and also subscribe to my
channel for weekly content on these
topics as some of you know I also have
an Instagram channel and my handle is
firm learning on top of that a few weeks
ago I put together a consulting
interview preparation checklist with my
best tips and tricks what you can do to
ace your consulting interview if you're
interested in that you can download it
for free below in the video description
I'm leaving a link there you just need
to sign up for the newsletter and then
you will get it to your inbox but now
without further ado let's jump into the
session in my
I think about four different types of
internships that you can do so corporate
consulting banking or startup right so
from a business perspective for me these
are the four categories and I believe
that either of them in theory works well
I believe that what comprise in terms of
course like to see us you having done
some kind of experience in confiding
before so especially now it's our target
is to get into Mackenzie or BCG or Bain
you know one of the mvd firms and
probably having done some internships at
one of them maybe two or one of the
smaller consulting firms maybe you know
lembaga or the big four firms PwC
Deloitte and then young KPMG so these
kind of a bit of smaller tears would be
great internships to do to prepare
yourself but you do not necessarily need
to do that another category that is
often also very guarded is internships
in corporate firms and especially
corporate firms that our potential
clients of confiding firms right so the
big blue chip companies especially in
Munich you are lucky that there are so
many no ducks 30 companies in Munich
cement and so on so these are companies
that are clients of confiding firms and
consulting firms love that if you have
internet as well because this shows then
that you have already seen the client
side of the whole thing you have already
have an understanding how it feels like
right to be at these kind of firms to
interact with these people who work
there so here as well I would encourage
you there as well and especially again
if you are Munich you have the best
opportunities because you just have all
these great household names just you
know after behind your door it's just
perfect
and yes just doing some entrepreneurial
things other work achievements are
interesting as well if you have a little
entrepreneurial venture maybe that you
build up during university with your
friends this just shows that you know
you're a bit of an entrepreneurial guy
who can show us out of the box you can
think outside of the box and this is
always very well when you buy the
consulting firms yes consulting firms do
look at extracurriculars they do look at
what you have done you know left and
right and I think the main rationale is
that for a consulting firm what they
will expect from people is not only that
you do your job well on the job right
not only that because your job well
being a consultant on the job but they
will also expect you to help out in your
office to take up some additional
initiatives in your office just to come
up with some great ideas as well but
then you will do on top of all your
consulting work right this really
expected from you at some point after
the first year or so that you really
take up responsibilities left and right
doing some additional projects helping
on in your office and that's effective
then you were able to commit your
sextortion is to some organizations that
you took the initiative in the past you
know maybe in politics or some other
force activities this just shows that
you are this type of person that to whom
it just comes naturally to do all these
kinds of things and which is why
extracurricular experience here is
important this way then honors and
awards this is kind of the first the
fourth experience section one thing that
I believe for some people is very
present and for other people they just
do not have it in their mind at all the
scholarships so I think that
scholarships can be very helpful and for
two things right first of course it
helps you do your own university degrees
because you get money and also a great
Network if you are on these scholarship
programs but it's also very good signal
to consulting firms because the reason
is that especially these be mbf
scholarship programs so if you don't
know it it's EMBs woodenness ministerium
for building one for song so it's one of
the big big ministerium and germany one
of the big government departments in
Germany and they have a scholarship
program and they have I think 12 or 13
different institutions that give out
their scholarships and probably the most
well-known is the student of tungsten
initiative term distortion focus but
then there are also all kinds of
scholarships each political party has
one of the institution but then there's
also there's different a torch in there
shaft all the big religions have an
institutions to which they give
scholarships and so on so just research
if you're not familiar with that it's a
very great opportunity and I don't at
least as far as I know you do not
necessarily need to be a german citizen
to get their money but we are on
research here but it's a great
opportunity both to get funding and it
is a really high regard it is highly
seen by german employers because it
shows them that you were already able to
go through
pretty pretty advanced recruiting
process a pretty advanced selection
process due to the source collar ship
thing because often they have been a
weekend off Assessment Center or
something like that that you need to go
through in order to get admitted to that
so that really shows that that you're
just up to the task
right and they now invite you to their
interview process you know they have
some some confidence that you were
already able to pass such a difficult
process in the past and at mckinsey at
least I I'd say that 60 70 percent of
the people probably had one of these
pmdf scholarships so it's pretty common
most of people have it and I really
encourage you to get it also for me it
was a great experience besides that of
course Dean's List other academic honors
try to collect the stuff as well and if
you have any prizes of course this is
always where we got it read and there's
no of course is then also the content
and then you should try to get a no CV
because this is the stuff that will make
you interesting for these bigs to energy
consulting firms I'm sure you have more
questions on that so I'm sure that later
we can also dive into that let me just
quickly go over the presentation first
more because now we are going to the
second element and this is now the
written application and this pretty much
consists of two main documents namely
the cover letter and the CV and the
cover letter yeah I know that many
people to read out about a lot oh my
dear what am I writing in this cover
letter right and I believe the truth is
that this is pretty much seen as a
hygiene sector and this means that you
know having a like a super great cover
letter this is not what will get you the
job right I mean nobody is going to say
oh wow this guy is just such an amazing
cover letter but of course you know if
you just met up here if you do you're
something that's unprofessional then
this will just be seen as a big no-go
and then of course you so it's important
just to get it right but don't believe
that this is not the most important
thing in the solar application and just
kind of three suggestions that I want to
give you three tips that I want to give
you for the cover letter first and this
is now either the third bullet make sure
that you're very clearly probably in the
first paragraph of your cover letter
that you communicate about three things
first when you want to
second in which office you want to start
and third what is the specific role you
want to start in I mean this for me I
like the main the most important points
of information that should be included
in a cover letter and but I like to read
lots of cover letters and friends also
sent me them where this is not included
so make sure that this kind of is
included just as a daisy points of
information that should be in there and
then also answer two things namely first
why do you want to work in contracting
what is your motivation and then finally
like why this firm I mean what entices
you pervert at making your ad BCG and so
on and I know this can be difficult
because I mean these firms are and
they're not that difficult is to compare
them but I think what's always something
great that you can draw on this is maybe
if you've been to a recruiting event and
you really enjoyed the people there if
you maybe you know a name or four
recruit also that you work to and I mean
now you know me right so if you want to
apply to McKinsey you can also say that
I talked to an alumnus of the firm and
it just really liked it right so I mean
just pointing out some personal
relationships that you have and just
pointing out that due to these personal
relationships this is what really
believes that you like the people that
you like the style it's like the culture
this is just one of the pointers you
could draw on if you talk about now
choosing a specific firm and if you
thought on the CV so here I know that in
Germany many people like the two-page CV
format
I believe using two pages for your
severe it's also okay for sure do not
use more than three pages I mean this
would be very bad just try to stick the
two and personally I believe that the
one page format is the way to go it's
the best format is just so amazing just
read everything on one piece of paper
just you can just grasp it so much
better I just love that and I'm sure
that the HR departments will of that is
there so whenever possible try to get it
down on one page CV and here you know I
know many people are saying oh hi
nervous I'm just such a great guy I just
put so much stuff in my life you know no
way I'm going to be able to fit that on
one page and I mean this is just
complete PS right I mean even if you are
like a CEO of the Ducks come to me with
30 years of work experience you will
always be able to put it on a one-page
CV so just push yourself are here to do
that regarding the CV I think the key
sections should be pretty much what we
discussed in the last page so you take
work experience extracurriculars on us
in the water and then also other
qualifications so these should be kind
of the main chapters that you then have
there and that you then discuss and
there's some more general remarks what I
see often made wrong in Seabees is
regarding the highlighting your
contribution and often people use
formulation such as you know we did
something our team did this we did
something in the Seabees in the bullets
that you're right on your CV make sure
that you very much focus on what you did
what your impact was what your
contribution was what do you achieve in
a specific job in the last internships
what did you do what was your
contribution and whenever possible also
quantify that yes so whenever possible
put a number to it to really make sure
that you know it's very tangible what
your achievements of your impact
actually is and now because I think now
I'm already over the time of the 50
minutes that I was supposed to talk just
a few quick thoughts on and all the
interview process right so the third key
building block of getting in so usually
there's three aspects of that you have
the CV interview you have a case
interview and you have an experience
interview and sometimes this can be a
bit mixed depending on this firm
sometimes you you know I have an
interview where the both the Syrians
have you and the case interview or to
let me where you at the case and then an
experience interview but just a few
brief point out on these three interview
types so just first explanation what is
the Syrians have you a severe
interviewers that you basically go over
the CB with your with your interviewer
right so this should be the interviewer
you should forget of an interviewer and
then common questions are things like
okay please introduce yourself
or please guide me through your CV so
these are some very basic questions that
you will find in almost every interview
process and just make sure that you have
a little concise talk prepared right so
if somebody asks you okay please give me
a little introduction about yourself
that this is no not you know the first
time you think about what to say but
that you have like a little talk maybe
five minutes or so perhaps they really
focus on the most important stuff you
are able to give them little
presentation the bought your CV about
your experiences in five minutes or so
to really guide your interview
I think this is really the most
important thing that you not get like
lost on one of the minor details in your
life but I able to give a nice and
concise presentation on your CV the
second is the case interview and I know
this is probably what most people are
afraid of when they think about
interviewing was confiding I mean this
is where people go crazy right and
really don't know what to do and here
just my main recommendation would be yes
you should read or you should practice
and yes you should read all the material
that's all there in the internet there
are lots of great resources where you
can prepare for cases what I believe you
should not do is now to learn 50
frameworks for all different sub types
of questions that you could be asked I
mean you would just go crazy if you do
that right so it's not about learning
lots and lots and lots of frameworks by
heart that they need to repeatedly tell
you process because this will also not
come across as natural this will not
come across as really know you finding
an innovative solution to a problem that
you would provided be in the case
interview but rather what I would
recommend you to do instead us prepare
two or three basic frameworks two or
three basic frameworks that you can use
to qualitatively structure problem
structure things and you know if you
just start learning start reading into
these frameworks I'm sure that after
some time you can really distill it two
or three ones that will really help you
to answer most of the questions yes
learn these frameworks practice them but
what we are enough no need to learn 50
frameworks for every little sub thought
and then the last thought regarding the
case interview what really helped me
when when I prepared for my interview
sirs that I paired I put together with I
think it was a wonderful lady at the
time that interviewed also was BCG and
some other firms and Weavin met probably
once a week or so and we sat together
and for each session we prepare the case
for each other and then we always
interviewed the other person and this
really worked out pretty well because
this way we both contractors we also got
a bit of an experience as being an
interviewer because this is also an
interesting experience right what do you
know the odds for them for the other
candidate and then we gave us feedback
so I would very much encourage you
because I believe the case in terms with
our practice or the more your practices
that
and you should not only practice by
reading but you should really practice
by doing some actual mock interviews and
this will be helpful to you this is what
really will help with an in the actual
interview and then finally the
experience interview or some people also
call it the impact interview this is an
interview type where the interviewer
will ask you to talk about specific
situation specific instances that you
faced in your life what happened there
and how you reacted to that and your
common questions are things like okay
please talk about the situation where
you had an interpersonal conflict with
somebody in your team and how you solved
it or maybe you had a conflict on a
Content matter right so you disagreed
with another person what the best way is
to move forward here and then how you
solved it may be situation where you
really showed leadership where you
really had an impact that you're really
proud of and what did you do how did you
achieve that so questions like that and
then where you are supposed to come up
with tangible situations to talk about
that but you really highlight your
leadership abilities your leadership
experiences and how that might be
applicable in the future and your my
three main recommendations would be
first these questions they're pretty
easy it's usually not be like you
surprises right so it's pretty easy for
you to foresee what types of questions
will be asked and exactly the questions
that I just told you and some basic
variations of these kind of things so
you need to prepare yourself in the way
that when you get thing ask these
questions you should never put yourself
in a position that then in the interview
on the spot you need to come up with a
crazy story that maybe happen two three
years ago whatever because this is not
how it should go let instead you should
at home already think about situations
like that you should have them very well
prepared and you should already have an
idea for these kind of main arch types
of questions what situation you would
talk about that you pretty much already
know what you're going to say and this
is not something that you should then
come up with on the spot in these
interviews and also just to warn you
here this experience interview
especially compared with the case
interview that's something that I feel
like many people significantly
underestimate you know they've lots of
time in practice on the case interview
but they don't really stand up the fam
at all on this experience interview part
at least by what I know what I know
about this experience interview was also
these has important applications of you
so really do yourself a favor to also
get the preparation down for that as
well and just make sure that you have
all of this ready yeah so this is just
my little imports my um of calls very
happy to get your question well first of
all Henry thanks so much for such an
insightful session and no worries that
you went a little bit over time actually
that gave me some time to breathe and
now I'm back all the participants many
of you submitted questions during the
registration process and we have it
right now so I will start with those
questions meanwhile feel free to ask
questions live right now you can raise
your hand and then I will unmute you and
you can phrase your question directly to
language so to start with Henry you have
a pretty interesting background with
degrees from several universities and in
different fields so how was that overall
experience of Education for you and how
did it help you and shaped you with your
carrier journey yeah and so to be honest
also form about that a couple of times
for me probably the most formative time
was while I studied in Munich at the
University of Munich at LMU I think this
is really that the time where from an
academic perspective I learned most even
though the later you know I was in
London it at Ellis Eve which is also
considered you know a good private
university later also I did an MBA also
of course and very expensive program
where you can you know spend lots and
lots of money on that for me really the
most formative experience is what I've
done here in unity at LMU you guys at TM
so just can encourage you just to take
advantage of that experience as much as
possible just engage and all the
different you know student clubs talk to
other people there's also great and
vibrant startup scene in Munich this is
really where I just took away and what
from and all my specific background you
know after after I school I just wanted
to study business but I was always also
interested in philosophy so for me was
also bit of an experiment just to try to
do a double degree then in in the
University of Munich so I just signed up
for these conventional programs the
philosophy program
Netta minor in history of art survival
studied in Munich and then also the
business one so first was to me more an
experiment to see you know how long I
can do it but then in the end it turned
out quite way and then for me also great
experience was in Munich the CDT and the
Center for digital technology and
management they have an honours degree
it's open for both TM students and LMU
students for me this was probably one of
the most formative experience at all
Munich I can highly highly recommend
that so especially for also still in the
beginning of the bachelor or also at the
beginning of the mass that you still
have time to do that
check out the CV TM program can really
highly recommend it yeah it's an
excellent program for sure
and for next question I will allow a
deal to face this question so here you
are done with the question then I can
come back to my other questions first of
all thank you very much mr. Heinrich for
the talk it's very useful keeping in
mind the increasing number of consulting
projects that are right now getting into
the sector of Technology what do you
think are the most valuable skill sets
skill sets within the consulting enya
yeah I think this of course not depends
a bit on what role exactly in consulting
you want to go for and probably also
what firm you're gonna go for so now
assuming you would go for you know
McKinsey or BCG or anything like that
you're the truth is that you know if you
go in there if you are concise and this
more generalist confiding profile is
still more people will look for most and
now of course if you want to do project
the technology if you want to maybe be
affiliated with the digital practice
then having some relevant experience
here of course would head and I think
that this is not no specific it's not
the case that now you need to have a
super specific skill set you know work
in digital technology project and
strategy consulting firms and myself I
mean I I'm not having now super focused
digital profile for myself and I still
did lots of delicious projects at
McKinsey because it just learn over time
you just pick it up
but of course it helps and probably
specifically you know everything that's
basically a hard password at the moment
really somewhat behave for right so if
you do something with data science if
you have some experience with AI but
even things like online marketing this
is something there were lots of big
companies struggle with you know
personalization at scale the whole you
know it's and the big ducks company and
I don't want to target my customers how
do i leverage my data to do that how I
make sure that everybody gets the right
ad for the things that they really need
no Big Data projects hard wine but also
network design system design and how do
I now improve the system landscape in
the company Auto integrate the energy
systems and so on so these are all
things that are relevant from the
strategy concise and perspective and you
will be able to leverage that there's no
one specific skill that you need to have
I think you can draw on all these
different types of backgrounds you know
of course if you're more interested in
you know IT consultant type of roads I'm
not I don't know if you want to work at
Accenture there and the technology arm
or something then it might get more
specific based on the role that you're
interested in so when I was a student I
did an internship for instance at
Accenture and I was working on an SAT
implementation project and there was
very super specific on you know business
intelligence BI being able to you know
bid these all up cubes and all this
stuff around that right and this it gets
more tailored more relevant to the
specific job but in general yes digital
skills text kids are they regarded it
will probably not be now the the super
great deal breaker so I mean as a
consultant the things that they usually
still go for us more this generalist
type of skill set but then having a
strong tech focus on one or two very
relevant skills will kind of be the the
cherry on top that then can really help
you to get in thank you next is
Christopher
can you hear me yeah yeah okay nice
thank you
first of all thank you for the short
overview I really liked insights my
question would be like I'm currently in
the second semester of my bachelor's
degree mm-hm and I'm also like aiming to
start like a double degrees from this
winter semester oh okay and like on the
home page for example of McKinsey they
usually write like you can apply for an
internship from your third semester own
but like is there like a certain point
or like playing time in your studies
that you would recommend like an
internship away say like at this point
in time it makes actually like sense to
start an internship because they can
actually work on some project no
knowledge yeah so yes so here my
recommendation would be or what you need
to understand to put it this way what
you need to understand is that first if
you apply and then you don't get in
usually you get a block of at least one
year sometimes even one and a half years
before you can apply again right so if
you basically apply after your second or
third semester and then you don't get in
then usually you cannot just apply again
one semester later and then these four
my knowledge this is not only the case
for McKinsey but for most of the other
consulting firms as well right so you
probably not apply if you feel like you
don't have a realistic chance at the
moment because this will really just
hurt you then because then you will not
be able to apply later again this just
the first consideration to have in mind
and then the second thing is that you
know if they hire an intern especially
at the MVB consulting firm so Mackenzie
BCG and so on they will put you on an
actual project team so you will be at
least in like 99% of the cases you will
work at the clients on an actual
engagement you will be in meetings with
clients alone you know the team will
depend on you and for these reasons they
would have let's say kind of some
minimum stand-ups that they want you to
get or to achieve you know if they hire
you for an internship
and so it's not the case that they
basically have kind of a staggered
requirement listed they think okay
somebody's only in the second semester
of The Bachelor then you know this is
the level he needs to be at a piece and
the fourth semester of The Bachelor and
this is the level of it need to get or
in the first master semester than I
expected more but pretty much the
standard of getting hired as an intern
it's pretty much the same doesn't matter
if you're on your bachelor on your
master right so and for these reasons
yes you can do an internship during a
bachelor also I did mine internship
after my fifth semester of my bachelor
and it's absolutely possible those would
be a bit careful because if you are you
know still early in your studies
probably also still a bit younger maybe
a bit less mature you know you also the
perception of you might also be even
more junior then maybe you're two years
from now so just be a bit realistic
about where you currently stand with
your skillset with your personality
whether you would really be able to nor
sit in front of senior clients or
whether maybe it makes sense to wait
another year or so to get a bit more
experience maybe have done another
internship until then you're really
ready to apply
thanks anguish I will take one question
from the questions that were submitted
before the passes participant asks is
there a moral focus on any particular
industry in German consulting sin then
others um yes so in general so in
general you need to understand that
actually Germany is a country that is
that likes confiding a lot yes okay so
for the German market for the confiding
firms is is one of the most important
markets in the whole world and in the
u.s. so so and these are McKinsey what's
the case that they they have split the
US and like three main offices and so
let me just I don't want to know I talk
about specific numbers but let's just
say that Beck Germany is like an
insanely important market and even if
you even if you control for the size of
the economy so for the GDP or whatever
you know consulting services play even
then placed in a larger role with many
other compared to many other countries
so for whatever reason German companies
like confided this is just affect and
what this means is that if you are here
in Germany if you work in Germany
probably you are also in terms of career
perspectives of you know the chances of
making it to partner and so on probably
are better than in in other countries
like UK or France or so on not only
because the size of the economy is
larger therefore you know more
opportunities but also many many
industries are more inclined to you know
work with contagions but then yes there
are some differences among industries so
I would say that especially if you work
for a large company like McKinsey you
will have opportunity to work in every
industry I mean there's pretty much no
industry that we do not serve or that we
didn't serve so it's not that you know
if you sign up with the company such as
McKinsey there's this one industry where
you will not work for sure but the truth
is also that some industries they are
just significantly less opportunities
and in other industries and for instance
I don't know for instance retail I mean
yes there are studies projects in retail
all the time and I did also trench up
retail projects during my time but you
know whenever you look at
the retail staffing newsletter so then
we have like regularly staffing you set
up sent out all the people so you know
what the current opportunities are you
click on your project and if you then
we're looking at the retail newsletter
often they're like three four five six
new things going on at a given point in
time and if you look at a ad for
instance advanced industries automotive
these more tech oriented industries you
have lots of pages so opportunities that
you could start right so just to give
you a bit of a sense of perspective so
there are some differences and
specifically banking is big automotive
to speak advanced industries as big
pharma can be very big so these
industries is very common not that big
are things like retail consumer goods
also the digital thing so companies like
Google Facebook and so on I mean doesn't
want to say that there are some
opportunities for all of these companies
but it's they are not better fee into
consulting than these more old-school
German tech companies I'd say yeah we
have another question that that goes in
line with this one in our Q&A so the
participant asks that would you
recommend to get into in-house
consulting of the industries that you
have mentioned and is it possible to
have a transition from in-house
consulting in this industries to the big
four our big three let's say yeah so
what depends on your goal I'd say right
so I think the main reason why people do
in Austin sizing is because they believe
it's it's pretty much comparable to a
trainee program I'd say right so you
started it you know I was consulting
firm and then you have these different
projects and for that you have exposure
to different departments you get to know
different people and then you build a
network in that company on this within a
video to hopefully it was that easy idea
to then do a nice transition to a good
senior role and I believe this is a
valid rationale it can work and of
course on the reputation of the in
Austin's hiding from stiffer but forever
firms or obviously Siemens has a very
renowned thing with simens management
consultants some other programs are
probably not that established but if
then this is I'd say viable I mean I
didn't do that first hand so but these
from what I've seen also and some
companies have worked together with
these and also consulting people what I
believe is not a good idea is to to
start in an in-house consulting firm
just then later to do the switch to mbb
or to to look for at least four four
four McKinsey I think about I cannot
imagine Singh a guy who transitioned
from it no I'm fighting for them this is
not to say that it's impossible but also
just in terms of the story I just feel
like it doesn't make much sense right I
mean if you want to do confiting
then why wouldn't you directly start
with the big consulting firms and if you
want to do corporate then rather start
in a corporate role but I mean I think
you need to be very clear tell a
convincing story here like one what your
ration air should be about that right so
probably not the best idea it's not
impossible but I wouldn't necessarily
recommend great Alberto you are next
yeah hi everyone and thank you for the
sessions is really helpful and
informative so really appreciate it
my question is so I'm currently in my
second last semester at home for my
master's degree in management and I was
I was thinking about applying to the big
three ending their Italian offices
because that's where I'm from
therefore I wanted to ask you if if to
your knowledge if there are any
variations or differences in the
recruiting process depending on where
the office is located and where could
you find information on how to account
for that and prepare for that and also
how much do McKinsey BCG in vein value
international experiences and if that's
actually something that can make a
difference or if you just should focus
on other things
oh yeah thank you yeah of course so
first I mean yes there can be some
differences regarding the application
process and usually at least with a
larger service these differences are not
huge
they exist just to give you an example
when I started at McKinsey there still
was something that was called a pious
PSP problem-solving test it was pretty
much I think somebody has maybe somebody
can put himself on mute because I'm
hearing myself double some grid echo
yeah so there was something like the PSP
the problem-solving test and this was
kind of a written test where you needed
to answer you know little like math
problems so you were really sitting
there in the office when you conducted
interviews and then they had like a
little written test nothing in Germany
at McKinsey they know they don't have it
anymore
but in some other countries they are
think they still do and then another
thing that is now currently tested at
McKinsey is House I know is it's kind of
an online game that they use it's I
believe they use it also in the very
first tweening process so this is
something that candidates need to do at
home and it's kind of a little game it's
about ecosystems where they need to make
sure that all the ecosystems aren't
balanced or something there's I think
you can also on the McKinsey career page
you can find some basic information on
that but I believe this is not there in
every country yet there because they're
just slowly testing it and then rolling
it out do bonus I'm not hundred percent
sure whether at the moment it's already
lies in German you're not mean to find
out you should just check the career
page of the local office so as you go to
McKinsey like the German McKinsey page
and they are on kuvira you will find the
basic information on how its run in
Germany and trust the same thing may be
true if you then go on the Italian page
so check out your local recruiting page
and then there would be the tricky
information and then at least after you
apply it and then if you get invited to
an interview then usually you will also
get additional information from the HR
team how exactly the interviews will be
run and what will be expected from you
so of course you will get that
information that in beforeand and
regarding the international experience
so I think what's what's usually not
that valued is frankly as languages so
now having language skills and lots and
lots of different languages is usually
not considered super important or
whatever
I think what's of course important is
English so that you have go through an
English skills and of course what many
consulting firms want is
language skills in the local office so
you know if you want to apply for German
role especially for client-facing role
then yes people will expect from you not
necessarily to be fluent but it needs to
have kind of business level Germans kids
and the same is true also for other
countries for their respective language
but usually it's not a huge factor nor
whether you can speak other languages
this way of course though it doesn't
hurt and when a neighbor you potentially
also to do projects in that country know
if you want to go there then during your
engagement regarding other experience
such as you know being abroad or
sometimes that having spent a semester
abroad internship abroad I think yes
this is Venu it so again it's more like
hygiene sector in the sense that I
believe if you people kind of expect you
to have it right so I mean if you have
it it's not like a huge class people
will not be like wow this guy is so
great because he was abroad but it's
more like the other way around if you
don't have it then people you know will
rather notice it in a negative way and
this is not to say that your chances are
zero you know if you have never worked
abroad as yours never done there's a
nest abroad but they're possible to get
in but this will be seen as you know
something negative and the rationale
here again is just you know you will
work frequently with people from other
countries also you know me working at
McKinsey probably 50% of my studies were
brought but not in Germany so you will
also be starved potentially on studies
outside of the German your outside of
your country and there you know you can
just give the people a bit of confidence
that you will handle the situation where
if you already show some international
experience
thank you very much I just realized we
are approaching towards the end of the
session and there are still a lot of
hands we can go a bit over time if you
want I mean I'm flexible that's great
and I would try to integrate as many ask
questions possible so next question is
our salaries higher in consulting invest
and South Germany 10 in East Germany so
I mean here there might be differences
not some but some but my general would
take on that is or maybe just to start
even on an international level so even
within one company at BCG or McKinsey or
whatever yes
salaries will be different country by
country so really you know adapted to
you know the local competitive situation
to the local living costs and so on and
actually Germany has pretty good
salaries actually I'd say compared to
other countries in consulting in January
this is also true for banking so if you
know go to UK or something
especially than if you're in London
especially given that they're the living
costs are so much higher
I believe the salaries in Germany are
really attractive and very interesting
now with in Germany at least with the
big firms like BCG McKinsey also the big
four you should usually expect that they
will not differentiate within Germany
and the reason also is that at least at
McKinsey you can pretty much really
change offices between Germany right so
I started actually in the Berlin office
and then I transitioned to the Munich
office data just due to private reasons
because my wife moves there so for these
reasons in general no there were no
differentiate between eastern and
western Germany though of course now if
you're looking into smaller confiting
from smaller boutiques or whatever then
maybe I mean in general of course it's
true that in general the average
salaries in the East and the water in
the West I see I'll take another
participant question from their Q&A
section and the question is it's no
secret that you need really good grades
to get into consulting do you think it's
problem
or even a no go if you didn't finish
your degree within the regular time
period and you took one or two semester
longer no I don't think so
I don't think so I mean of course it's
good to so then I have some kind of
ration a god I mean hate it's always
possible to come up with some more less
convincing reason why why you did that
right I mean I'm sure you have a reason
otherwise you know you would have done
it faster so maybe you've been abroad or
maybe it did some cool internships maybe
you did something else some parody that
really took your time and then I do not
think that this is a huge issue of
course then if you took longer and then
also your grades are not that that good
and so on I mean then this can you know
add up to maybe an impression which is
not that great of course it's helpful to
have completed it in in the regular time
but this in most cases should not be a
huge deal breaker okay so there's a
question from Joe and in the chat box
and also a couple of participants during
registration submitted the same question
that they have a couple of years of
experience reading from five to two to
five years and they have been working on
this for quite some time like getting an
internship into in-house consulting or a
big for consulting and all the tips that
you provided intersession in the
beginning they have been working on it
on CV and cover letter and all those
stuffs and still things are not really
working so what would you advise to such
people okay
I mean now here you would really need to
look into the specifics right so I mean
it might be the case that there's a
problem with your documents and so here
you should really make sure that these
are okay so you know from a formal
perspective it's all there and so I
would recommend that you really work
with some people whom you trust would be
a good judge of that
so then it catches some feedback and
actually if you're interested in that on
my youtube channel I have recently made
a video about CVS where I actually
review real examples of CVS of other
people and there are also lots of tips
and also put specific things just
interested in that check out the video
on my youtube channel but so just make
sure that your material is there and
then if you still get not invited
then unfortunately you know the profile
just doesn't seem to meet the criteria
unfortunately and you know of course but
then I would also recommend you and I'm
probably the only shot that you have is
just to try to network right so try to
go maybe to career fairs with some HR
people maybe then also if you have the
opportunity to talk to one person
face-to-face and maybe you can just find
another guy who works at the firm just
really can get you some some extra
feedback on your profile maybe also how
you frame certain things and I mean then
maybe you you get a shot off you know at
least getting invited to the interview
because anything this was also one of
the questions just to quickly touch on
that the question is you know does
networking head can you get into the
firm you know just because you have in
Germany you say vitamin B so your
relationships to some people right and
usually for most companies you can get
to the interview by that right so if you
know the right people and if they really
like you and they're really and if you
find a partner who really believes
you're great guy he can push you to get
an interview but then from the interview
you're on yourself I mean then in the
interview you will then be assessed by
by a team and then nobody will sabotage
the whole recruiting process for you
just to get you through and even if a
partner would do that that would be
probably wouldn't work and what be also
super bad first reputation so yes it can
help you networking can help you to get
an interview but then from the interview
on your self so if for whatever reason
your profile just isn't there then
really try to talk to these people try
to convince them but then of course it
very difficult and but yeah but this is
in the chance that you have thanks now
lorina asks what was what what was your
struggle while getting into consulting
if you could share a couple of thoughts
on that and in line with it I will
quickly face the next question as well
if you could also share your experiences
of two excellent projects that you
teased in consulting and through most
challenging projects that you did in
consulting okay so I mean my challenges
I mean to be honest I was kind of lucky
because I was in a Bachelor and I just
wanted already just a couple of
internships and I just wanted thought to
do a contracting internship and then I
just applied to a couple of
and actually than the McKinsey one was
one of the earlier interviews and I
think I was well prepared I did lots of
mock case studies there's a couple of
other interviews before and then I had
the McKinsey one and then I got in for
the internship and then actually also
can fit than the other ones because for
whatever reason I was you know McKinsey
was kind of my dream form than to work
at that time and then then I just signed
up there and then what's of course
possible is once you do the internship
then if you perform where then you can
get an offer to work members of some
afterwards and then actually because my
master was only one year so sometimes
it's kind of time limit that you know
you need to then decide to join after a
certain amount of time but one year
usually is fine so then I was able to
basically start my mask already with the
offer of them joining McKinsey
afterwards which was of course is super
comfortable position so I guess I just
was lucky and for these reasons I didn't
have any huge struggles to be honest but
then of course in consulting or through
the two best in Traverse projects then
you you will struggle a lot then on the
job right I mean everybody would have
bad projects and this can be like super
tiresome just to share two stories and I
mean what one thing was
just to talk about one thing here I
think in the end what it comes down to
to whether you enjoy a project or not
it's not so much on the content it's not
so much on the topic but even though of
course some topics some projects can be
more interesting than I don't know doubt
but what I believe what most people if
you like then also who won't talk to
some of our colleagues the deciding
sector is your team and your clients the
team that you work with probably number
one and then they clients to work with
number two and I was once in a tough
situation where I didn't get a long way
with the team I worked with and I also
didn't got a long way with the client or
whether the main clients that I was
responsible for and this really was a
difficult situation because after some
time you know you need to every Monday
morning you fly there then you get into
the team room and then there so we had
atmosphere in the team room then you
talk to the clients then there's a weird
atmosphere with the clients and then you
know also then on top of that the stress
of working late every day of then
talking to the part that's what I'm not
happy and so on I mean this was really
an experience that we're just or it were
just it's so tiresome weather it crushes
you so much over time psychologically
but here I think the good part is in
confiding and and I think everybody you
know if you work in consulting at some
point in time you would have an
experience like that but everybody will
have one or two bad projects you can
talk about but the good thing is and I
think this is really a contrast compared
to industry you know after two three
four five months once the project is
over you know the cops are newly mixed
again right so you can work together
with new colleagues you can work with a
new company and you can basically start
again from a fresh slate then of course
over time you really get to know the
people you really enjoyed working with
the one partner you really enjoyed the
project need you really laughed it was a
really great guy and then you can stick
together with these people and then try
to work more and more with these people
and then this is how you create the soil
kind of set of people who support each
other and then it's just a great
experience if you contrast that with
corporate you start in a team in
corporate you have the these teammates
you have this one boss you're one team
which you will work with and then
usually for the next three four five
years this would be your family right
and you can either be lucky and it works
out really well or for whatever reason
you can be
really unlucky and you just really don't
get along with these people at all and
then basically your only option is to to
switch jobs I mean you you will never
you know hear that right I mean if
you're really some point in a position
and somebody just need to leave and I
mean this is just about contacting just
a lot of flexibility just to talk about
a positive example is where this is
whenever all these things come together
so it wasn't just one of my my recent
ones it was an automotive company an
automotive supplier and the topic itself
was interesting but not super exciting
but we really got got along with the
clients really where there were also
some nice junior people then on the
evening sometimes you would go out with
them on the weekends would because I was
living in the same city with them we
would meet you would have some drinks
the team was super cool we all got along
super where the product wasn't going
well everybody was setting everybody was
just having a good time the impact was
bad all worked out really great with
this of course also always cool if you
can see that what you're doing really
impacts the company in a positive way
and you're really helping and if all of
this comes together then it's just so
great and then you'd also don't mind
anymore if you work late or if you know
work until late in the evening or
something like that and this is really
when you laugh doing your job and it
really lasts coming into the office
every day and the truth is it just will
not be like that every day but you will
also come across these products and
they're just amazing and then over time
you can really choose more and more the
people you want to work with and this is
just I believe the magic of working
contracting huh yeah quite exciting I
would say and the good and bad both
things are that it will end I mean yeah
exactly
I'll take the next question from you he
asks what is the percentage of
non-germans and non-europeans in
McKenzie and I think in general how much
focus is there in German scene in
consulting about international people I
will combine it with another question
about the language so the participant
asks that my German is at intermediate
level and I'm working on it
but meanwhile I do want to get into
consulting and what would you advise me
in
on this stage yeah well first of all the
the quotas of Germans and so on and of
course if you look at the company on a
global level then it's you know I say
it's representative of the geographies
that you are based on right I mean
there's the US office there of course
most of the people will be from the US
and Germany most people would be from
Germany in Asia under specific countries
the most people would be from the local
geographies so kind of on a global level
I'd say it's very much mixed of course
and the German offers the majority of
the people will be German and the main
reason for that is that you will need to
be fluent in Germany or at least kind of
another advanced level as a German
speaker to work in the German office of
both consulting firms and again now if
you may be working IT consulting where
maybe you're also not that client-facing
and so on there might be some
differences but at least for the big MVB
consulting firm some McKinsey BCG Bain
also you can assume that then yes you
will need to speak the language so what
can you do if you do not have that level
of proficiency and the German language
but you want to still work in Germany
and I mean frankly I believe me the only
thing at this again if you now look at
the MVB consulting firms the only roads
that you might be then open for are more
kind of the back office roads the
analytics teams the support teams and
you there can be some exciting
opportunities as well so special ops II
have some IT skills there there are
whole statistics teams right data
modelling data science teams to then
support the consultants from the
background and then yes maybe you will
also then a few days drawing the team on
the ground at the client to help them
maybe build a model together with
somebody then you can support them in
these ways they are done also research
team so we can difficult our and I
research an information so you know
whenever confides and needs to collect
information from reports or whatever
then there are these research guys they
can then draw on so then conduct beef
analysis for them but the truth also is
here so even though I'd say these are
interesting jobs and they're also very
fairly compensated
it's it's not the it's not what you are
envisioning if you work in consulting
right I mean it's not really the life of
a client facing on heightened and also
within the firm so
so even though this is kind of a
constant topic right I mean I'd say the
catch I mean don't people try lots to
not to not now create a class system you
know in the firmware you know one people
are above the other or something that
just the fact that you know there's one
level with the client facing confidence
and then there's the other level with
with all the rest of all the people
supporting them and I think people do a
very good job of you know trying to not
make these people feel bad and trying to
encourage them and to have a great and
inclusive some environment and I believe
in companies like McKinsey this works
really well but I would ask myself
whether this is really the experience
that that you want to have or whether
than there are maybe are some other
opportunities that maybe suit your
profile su chio goes to the better
because also the truth is why it does
happen
I mean sometimes people make the switch
so I know also a couple of people who
did that from these more back office
research roads in true than the client
facing confession role so it's not
impossible but I'd say it's it's very
rare and rather than usual so this is
not something you should count on often
doing this which it's just very uncommon
it there are some examples but is just
very uncommon and you shouldn't build
your career based on the idea then after
some years you just do the transition so
this is not something you can count on
Thanks
just checking other questions well very
quick note I mean we are almost there
already over the time still I will try
to incorporate all the questions I think
I will take one from the please
submitted questions and that is are you
part of McKinsey alumni network and
could you share what role does it play
after the exit um yes I'm part of the
alumni network and I think everybody is
who leaves the firm in good standing so
yes
frankly I haven't used it that much yet
because I also directly got a new job I
believe there's kind of a portal where
you think and get in touch with other
alumni and then there are also regular
events but on the Alumni meet and so
thank you haven't really made use of
that and so I believe it can be helpful
it's probably not now you know a
life-changing experience of being in
this alumni network but of course there
many alumni now work in inferential
roads around the world and all those
companies and are reaching out to them
via either we are the official network
or we are LinkedIn or some other ways I
believe of course is helpful for you in
the long run but I I trust this is
similar with other big brands this way
and I mean you also targeted this during
earlier questions that it's a very
high-performing job and it takes a lot
of time so however it also depends on
country to country and office to office
a culture and working hours so how is it
exactly in Germany yeah yeah I mean
there lots of stereotypes around that
something the stereotype is that the
German office is one of the worst
offices in terms of work-life balance
German loss to work after work probably
only topped in the negative sense by the
Italian office so the attendant office
is considered in worse and also the
Japan office is considered very bad and
we disappoint like the tops to be right
and then on the other side people who
are considered to be very chooses all
the Nordics so if you are working the
Nordics this is considered very
laid-back but also the Dutch office for
instance this is to be considered
quietude and then the rest is somewhere
in the middle I mean here again I mean
probably in terms of direction
this is foo right but again it differs
not project-by-project and also the
people that you work with I mean some
projects just will make you work longer
than other project just because how the
setup is just for the requirements are
and there are also just some teams some
project needs who are more sensitive to
work/life balance than others and here
again this is more a bit also something
that you will learn over time to kind of
find the people that you like to work
with and then maybe these can also be
the people you know do not push you want
to after midnight every night right I
mean because I just can be super
tiresome Arthur afterward so but yes the
truth is that you will work much longer
than many other jobs the positive side
of that and this is also true for the
German office at least at McKinsey what
I experience is that the weekends are a
very rare respected right and this is I
believe a big difference too for
instance banking so if you work in
Frankfurt in the method form with
coordinates X or whatever you can expect
to be in the office every Saturday every
Sunday you know weekends every week this
is not the case with the big consulting
firms so I mean yes there's really a
hard business meet and as it's known is
very very urgent and yes you will be
asked on the week we work on the weekend
and then this will be also expected from
you but probably for me the septons five
six seven times or so in the in the in
the years I've been at McKinsey so it
does happen but not super frequently and
so weekends are very well respected and
I believe those too because great Idol
is still raising hand so I will allow
him to talk sure yes my question is does
an MB add anybody would do somebody who
wants to enter consulting and my second
question is is it possible to transition
from consulting to Investment Banking
after getting three to four years of
experience in consulting yeah so the
first question I mean yes an MBA heads
or no let's put it differently I'd say
confiding firms hire a lot of MBAs this
is affect especially if you know did an
MBA at one of the bigger well respected
programs you have a good chance of them
getting hired by consulting I mean
either the DNC NBA
Frantz and then also on the Singapore
campus and this is one of the MBA
programs that is very close to confiding
firms or a lot of people than joint
comprising also a lot of people with
other backgrounds before with industry
background corporate backgrounds later
joined and we be consulting firms so
this is for sure a path that you can
take but this is not to say that you
need to have an MBA to get into
consulting especially in Germany I'd say
that MBAs are still not that popular
right so for instance doing a PhD in
German is much more popular than doing a
an MBA and it's not at all a must-have
criteria to transition into the
converging role so of course for now it
depends on your profile right for some
profiles it can really help maybe you
have a more specific corporate role kind
of more technical role of some years of
experience and a big corporate or
something then from that it maybe can be
a bit hard to not directly transition
into strategy consulting firm and then
an MBA can really help you to to make it
more interesting to employers to maybe
also broaden or your horizon a bit and
then for these kind of profiles that can
can be very helpful to to have an MBA
now you need to remind me of the second
part of the question again
um second part of the question was I
think can you transition into Investment
Banking yeah yeah from consulting after
yeah so yes this is possible and I've
also seen I mean I know of different
people who did you know of course its
head for that then during your confiding
time you did a relevant project right so
for instance you did lots of due
diligence Asst you worked maybe close to
emanate things and so on but of course
you need to realize that your diligence
is probably are the worst projects out
there in terms of work-life balance
so because due diligence is also not
only two weeks three weeks four weeks
it's a very short amount of time you
work together with lots of other
professionals of private equity and so
on and I mean I and you one guy who was
just crazy I mean he was literally crazy
and either to one due diligence after
each other and like for a year or three
years or so I mean if you're if you're
this is what you want to do then I mean
feel free right but I mean you know you
just need to realize that this is them
probably that the type of stuff that
investment firms investment banking
firms will be interested in but this is
the stuff that really is one of the
toughest stuff to do and of course
there's also a middle way maybe you do
that occasionally and then you know do
that for two or three weeks and then you
go to more normal projects and then you
do good remittances again and of course
also some other project work in the
corporate finance right and so on but
maybe it's not like the delusions all
the time can also be interesting to
banks but just be aware that probably
then you need to make sure that you
really also go into that direction a bit
in confiding because I believe if you
just the digitalization projects or
marketing and say it's you know in
quantizing and then you want to
transition into an investment bank
probably that's going to be a bit
difficult rich well I think with this we
are done with most of the questions and
we will end the session over here thank
you so much once again all the
participants another huge thank you to
Heinrich I will quickly launch a survey
please let us know how did you how did
you like the session and you all know me
you
have my details contact details so do
let me know if you want more such
sessions and very quickly apologies to
be nervous in the beginning I mean you
have seen my sessions with AES this
won't happen again and Henry's thanks so
much for covering the report thank you
don't worry don't worry thank you yet
again all of you who want to get in
touch with language and each has a
YouTube channel and he's also there on
Instagram with the handle name form
learning
he shares excellent YouTube videos on
the same topic feel free to follow him
feel free to reach out to him and have a
great weekend
thank you so much guys thank you for you
guys and enjoy the weekend all the
better to you so that's it for those of
you who watched until the very end thank
you so much I appreciate it and if you
still have any questions that you also
want to have answered just leave a
comment below in the comment section and
I'll do my very best to answer every
single one again please hit the like
button please subscribe to see even more
from me and also turn on the
notification bear to get informed
whenever I release in your video good
weekend to all of you this has been
highly from firm learning until next
week